Joseph Stalin got the nuclear bomb from
Communists working in in the US so this
idea that there was this sort of like
Witch Hunt that was completely baseless
never quite made sense to me it's not
that they're saying have you had
communist ideas they were asking were
you a member of a secret organization
taking orders from a foreign power
intentionally designed to destroy your
current political system and Implement a
totalitarian dictatorship based on
violence Michael is so awesome to have
you back we've had you on the show a
couple of times and I will be honest
with you when we were coming to Austin
we were like we've had Michael on you
know we've probably talked about a lot
of the stuff that we could talk with him
about blah blah blah and then it's a WAP
it's a WAP that's it we've tapped that
well it's not a deep well we have
drained his intellectual balls that's it
there's nothing left right but then we
went for dinner and we just had the most
incredible conversations about all sorts
of stuff and we found out that your
balls are indeed still quite full yeah
they are full of intellectual you are
welcome no man but it was awesome and
are they half full are they half
empty I'm trying to be
serious let's find out yeah um and uh we
talked about lots of different things
and I was sitting there the whole time
thinking why are there no cameras here
cuz it would have been even more awesome
if we had that recorded there's no way
that conversation could be aired that is
true but we're going to try to to do the
part of it that we can do on camera okay
okay okay so I should take my pants off
now and also Melissa Chen was there have
you had her on she's terrific yes we've
had her on she is the most difficult
guest I've had and I've said this to her
public her face and I've said it
publicly like every aspect of having her
on my show is a pain in the ass even
though I adore her why would you pain
she was complaining about the thumbnail
and she was late and it was a whole
thing like I had to reschedule three
times I was I I kind of admire the diva
aspect of it to be someone as beautiful
as her complaining about the thumbnail
drove me crazy I'm like you're knockout
you know you're a knockout yeah I mean
just like you Michael well I am an
underwear model you're an underwear
model yeah sheath underwear. comom go to
sheath and use promo code malice for 10%
off it's the underwear that has a
separate pouch for both parts of your
right can we
concentrate Michael put your pants away
I know you've been told that many times
before it was created by a guy from the
Iraq War because it was hot down there
over
there okay how do we segue from that to
a serious I I Michael let's talk about
mcarthism
sure I mean that is a hell of a segue
it's a
segue but no one of ballsy topic there
it is I did it one of the things we were
talking about at dinner is there's lots
of stuff that we have a conventional
narrative about yes that I think I'm
going to cut you off just no go no no
you help yourself man I think everything
has a conventional narrative and at a
certain point when people become what's
called red pilled you have that moment
where you're like oh crap like literally
everything I've taught is a narrative
now the narrative might be true but it
is still a narrative cuz humans
communicate not through reason but
through
stories yeah that's a really good point
story is a very powerful way of getting
people's attention and actually of
misleading people absolutely and also
cuz we are emotional thinkers not
rational thinkers and that applies to
all of us to some extent so when you
have a story that kind of makes sense
and makes you feel a certain way it's
going to be far more persuasive than any
charts and graphs which can often be
faked anyway and also as well with a
story you can make it incredibly simple
it's the story of Good and Evil you know
the hero's journey whoever the hero may
be we identify with the hero and then
therefore it becomes emotional and we
don't want to look at the nuance and
complexity of the issue are you is that
passive aggression no the subtitle of
the white pill is a tale of Good and
Evil so yeah you're kind of dropping my
mask yeah good and evil does exist but
uh the reason I brought up mcarthism I
always had this deep suspicion about
that thing because when I was
researching my book and long before that
frankly like Joseph Stalin the most evil
dictator in the 20 in the 20 Century oh
now I mean it's a it's a it's a f it's a
what off it's a it's a kill off it's a
yeah but yeah it's a camp off I don't
know sure Camp off is something very
different mate well I don't go to that
many gay parties anyway um not that
many just the taste just a little flavor
yeah u i mean Joseph Stalin got the
nuclear bomb from Communists working in
in the US right so this idea that there
was this sort of like Witch Hunt that
was completely baseless and that
mcarthism was about hunting down people
who weren't at all Communists Etc never
quite made sense to me but I'd never
bothered to look into it so we're
sitting there over dinner and I was like
Michael given that we talking about
destroying narrative tell me about and
you were just like I did throw up you
literally sickening so tell us about
mcarthism well first of all I had a
quote from the my book the white pill I
don't have it in front of me but there
was a playwright um Molly Thatcher Molly
day Thatcher I think it was her name was
and she goes there were no witches like
the term itself is intellectually
dishonest but there were she goes no
tried to talk to someone the left and
tell them that there were no Communists
in the unions in Hollywood in politics
who were working systemically under
orders from a foreign Nation to
implement a violent overthrow of the
state and Implement you know a
totalitarian dictatorship she goes they
know better because that term is
intellectually dishonest and and
ridiculous and Arthur Miller who wrote
The Crucible to which was kind of a um
uh analogous to McCarthy era years later
was like we didn't have it in our
framework uh that all these things that
we hated about Hitler originated in the
Soviet system the secret police the
camps turning families against each
other you know I don't have the L list
off to my head it's also in the book but
Arthur Miller is like like all these
awful things that we hate about the
Nazis they got from they or had PR at
least preceded them in the Soviet system
so the term itself McCarthyism is also
intellectually dishonest because
McCarthy was a Senator uh the house on
American Activities Committee was in the
house and that preceded him uh to some
extent um and the question wasn't it's
portrayed as um people were just members
of this party like it's not like they
were like Francis were you ever a member
of the green party this was a criminal
organization under foreign control you
you know engaged in terrorism and and
violence and all sorts of horrific and
Espionage and Espionage all sorts of
horri activity but it's portrayed as
just basically instead of voting D or R
you're voting C they don't believe in
voting the whole I mean the whole point
is to destroy democracy and they were
influential in getting Hitler into power
in uh Germany because they're like we're
not going to Ally with the the leftist
party the Socialist Party and they
called them what's it called them social
fascist or whatever the term was I
forget what the term was but so it's and
it's just interesting because this is
the one time in the US where leftists
were cancelled and it's portrayed as the
second worst thing to ever happened in
America other than slavery and from
their perspective it is because this is
and again this isn't leftis in the sense
of we need health care for the poor uh
you know people who can't afford college
should get a handout and it's going to
earn back for the society because yeah
we're paying for their schooling but
they're going to become doctors and
Engineers this is better for everybody
this is a violent totalitarian ideology
uh discussed in secret uh and and with
consequences as you saw such as you know
Stalin getting the bomb and things like
the Korean War and all sorts of other
things I think as well Michael that the
there's a little bit of a gray line to
me which is people are allowed to
believe ridiculous things sure you know
I don't think that we should I mean this
again this is a great
for example there are people who
describe themselves as socialist and
there's somebody who has seen socialism
close up and seen the horrors of
socialism I think that they are demented
and stupid to put it bluntly however I
don't think they should have their
professional opportunities curtailed
just because they identify as being
socialist so to me there's always a Gray
Line C by whom Sorry ciled by whom ciled
by whom but so for instance if you are
you going to hire a Clansman am I going
to hire Clansman there's not many of
them you going to hire someone from the
national front I'm not going to no they
don't exist anymore but but do you see
look let's stop playing games I'm not
playing games no no I talking to him no
no no but but no no but there circular
firing but there was a very that's the
Polish communist yeah but there was a
very interesting case about 15 years ago
when the BMP was still the British
national party who were our kind of
version of the far right there was a
teacher who was fired for being a member
of the British national party and to
me there's always that Gray Line do you
see what I mean there's a difference
between the government does it and when
you do it privately yeah it wasn't that
you was illegal for you to hire a
Hollywood screenwriter who was a
communist and they often just changed
their names that no consequences if not
we're you know valorized for their
courage in the face of adversity lilan
Helman went to her grave Unapologetic uh
for her defense of Stalin and again this
is not that they were simply I like
communism this is I want Stalin to have
control over America this is the the
they're trying to create a gray area
where in my view there is none and I
agree with you that if someone's a
teacher you know this is something we
need to worry about because if it's like
if the government's just picking and
choosing who could be a teacher so on
and so forth but McCarthyism broadly
speaking uh although it does speak to
the government uh um committees that
were investigating this it also speaks
this idea of do I want people like this
working for me and if I discover that
they're secretly doing this and uh you
know putting their ideas their demonic
ideas into my films or my books or so on
and so forth do I want this person in my
payroll I think that's a not as that is
not only a legitimate question it's an
unavoidable question because everyone
listening to this there are people whose
views they would find so abhorent that
they would never hire them yeah right
Michael maybe it's helpful at this point
to actually given that not many people
know history particularly of that period
to actually explain what happened during
that so-called mcarthism what what was
actually being done well I mean this is
a kind of a long
so okay there's just so many moving
Parts here and I'll try to break down as
as efficiently as possible the thing and
I'm going to start with the present day
and this is why I'm I'm just
anticipating all the push back because
it's it's just very maddening and
frustrating so Boomer conservatives have
in the same way that the definition of a
racist is someone winning an argument
with a leftist right so
the the definition of a communist is
someone who Boomer conservatives don't
like right and they'll tell you with a
straight face that Joe Biden is a
communist and and all this other stuff
Joe Biden is a corporate hack he does
not want the government running all
industry there and and most people who
in America you know are left of center
let's suppose the Democratic Party uh
are not Hillary Clinton's another
example uh maybe she has totalitarian
Tendencies just in a personality wise
she's perfectly happy to have Wall
Street Run everything the Communist are
and Wall Street are not friends in the
sense that they are content to have Wall
Street Run everything they want the
state to run everything and you might
kind of try to evade the issue and be
like well at the end of the day it's
just the same it's really not the same
it's is having a monopoly as opposed to
having you know enormous corporate
control there there's certain
distinctions I'm not saying either is
good or is bad I'm just saying they're
not interchangeable um
so as a result of this they can't wrap
their heads around some of the biggest
anti-communists were hardcore leftist
Harry Truman you know is is a great
example of this he became president
after FDR and though they were kind of
shaking hands with Stalin to fight
Hitler that quickly fell apart after um
World War II and the Cold War happened
you know that's you know it was
Churchill in I forget it was in Nebraska
maybe he gave some speech in American
college and he coined the term Iron
Curtain he said Iron Curtain has fallen
over Europe and the good good guys were
on this side and the bad guys were on
that side and what's shocking to me and
one of the reasons I wrote the white
pill is it is completely indisputable
that for decades this was the central
foreign policy issue for everyone on
Earth you know it's you had uh you know
the Communist second world the Western
first world who's going to win and you
know it was not at all obvious or was
not at all clear that the West Was going
to win Sputnik was a great example of
this they got satellite into space
before we did this was proof that the
Soviet system is great and you know can
and
uh when Germany was divided into East
and West it's like all right this is
kind of proof of concept and North North
Korea was doing better than South Korea
until I think the early 80s because they
were getting subsidies uh um from the
USSR and from um the Soviet Union so
what happens is you have the Korean War
you know very quickly uh the early 50s
right after World War II and we were you
know we had bde right because we we won
World War II uh even though the so the
Russians like lost so many more people
than we did
like we kind of we emerged unscathed
like America became the UND indisputed
Undisputed leader of the Free World and
then it's like all right now the fact
that the Korean war was a draw this
really changed that narrative and this
is why the Korean war in America is
still called like the Forgotten War
because what's the story here like World
War II is a great story good guys versus
bad guys and we kind of don't talk about
Stalin right uh World War I okay it was
a disaster it was a mess but it's like
The Narrative kind of is like don't get
involved in international Affairs if you
don't need to you know what a tragedy so
on and so forth Korea Vietnam is more
talked about what happened here and the
reaction as opposed to why are we there
to begin with we had our asses hand to
us you know what happen when they teach
the Vietnam War here they don't really
teach about what happened to Vietnam
after it's just like we were there you
know we were kind of routed and like now
let's talk about something else it's
very there's no followup uh and this
happens a lot with media narratives a
good example I remember even I don't
know the conclusion to this uh just to
kind of sorry sidebar I remember Greece
was having issues with their national
debt and deficit right and the EU and
Merkel were putting pressure on them and
you had this far-left party we like
we're going to repudiate the debt we're
not going to pay it back and the eu's
like we're not going to do you can't do
that and they got voted in and then
everyone just stopped talking about it
like there was no followup here by the
way of what happened after that uh um
parliamentary election where that farle
party got in anyway um so as as a result
of this kind of international rivalry uh
there was it was discovered that during
the 30s and there's a great book about
this called the red decade to what
extent communism really captured the
hearts and minds of Western
intellectuals it was much worse in Great
Britain than the states uh much much
worse uh because what you had people who
were openly talking about like look if
we can't get it democratically we're
going to get it through Revolution and
and things like this and this guy was a
I think the chairman of the labor party
um so you have these Congressional
investigations they found lots of stuff
they also accused perfectly innocent
people or people who had communist
sympathies and in many cases you know
their lives were wrecked um so this is
just a testament in my opinion to some
extent to the inefficiencies of
government and Congress is not really
interested in finding truth Congress is
interested in grandstanding but that
term McCarthyism applies to many
disperate Concepts that are flated
together and thrown away and it I agree
it is important for people to have
access to ideas and to be able to hold
whatever ideas that they want but I
don't think anyone believes with a
straight face that no matter what ideas
someone has they should never you know
not be fired from their jobs maybe
government is a different situation
because that's a free speech issue First
Amendment issue no it's it's it's a very
interesting point that you raised and
it's something that I really struggle
with because if you believe in free
speech then everybody should be able to
you know have the they have the right to
their ideas but yet if you are pragmatic
you realize that some ideas are so
abhorent that you wouldn't want to let
this person with incredibly abhorent
ideas through the front door but the key
is it's not that they're saying have you
had communist ideas they were asking
were you a member of a secret
organization taking orders from a
foreign power in intentionally designed
to destroy your current political system
and Implement a totalitarian
dictatorship based on violence that's
not the same as being a member of the
green party or being you know a member
of a Socialist Party yeah Michael and
then what happens in the 60s because the
The Narrative is and this is the
alternative conventional narrative is
that uh western western Communists sort
of realized that
communism in terms of dividing people by
social class wasn't going to work in the
west the workers were not going to rebel
against the the the boura because they
all sort of thought you know the the
American dream is everyone thinks
they're going to be a millionaire one
day so why would we tax millionaires
type of thing and then in the 60s they
kind of go okay we'll find a different
way to divide people and we'll divide
them along race we'll divide them along
sex we'll divide them along sexuality
Etc is that do you buy that or is there
a different yeah that but I would just
uh uh edit that slightly it's not that
we will divide them it's that people
instead of being divided by class and
irrevocably divided by class the whole
point there's this concept under Marxism
called polylogism which is like you know
oh you're bis you could never understand
my uh um workingclass thinking because
we're fundamentally uh inherently
different on a metaphysical level which
is why Lenin was like all right we just
got to slaughter these people because I
can't fix you like like you are a member
of the bisi and you will die member of
the bisi they don't really like stick to
it entirely because there were lots of
you know these kind of champagne
socialists limine liberals uh caviar
Communists who would like they perfectly
welcomed in with open arms but that was
kind of the ex um approach to being like
well there's just some people there's no
reasoning with and and that is true
broadly speaking but it doesn't sort out
by class at all in in practice so then
as you as you saw correctly James
Lindsay is the king of this uh his book
race Marxism they took that polylogism
and they applied it to you know
different kind of identity politics and
it's been enormously successful and you
can see it every single instance where
you see as a black woman it's like well
hold on a minute I mean that's a
nonsensical way to precede a sentence
because the claim is do all black people
or all women or all black women think
this no you're one data point so I'm not
I'm not in position to speak as a Texan
or as someone from Ukraine or as as a
Jew or as a former New Yorker as an
American to some extent I am but to say
that like well as an American blah blah
blah it is a bell curve and is a range
but it's presented as each person kind
of becomes the Emperor of their own
little niche and it also is a very
effective um argument t uh technique
because well you're a white man you
can't understand what it's like to be a
black woman which is true to some extent
you can't understand that experience of
24/7 living that lifestyle but you could
certainly understand that person's ideas
and be a meable to having life be better
for them and and hear them out and it's
also a very very very effective trick in
order to silence people of your own race
or background who disagree with you yes
because you're like I'm the spokesman
for this person and then if this person
challenges me well then you're a traitor
to this group well I I think people
underestimate to what extent this is
metaphysical so uh in a in in this this
kind of discourse race is something that
is a state of grace so in this worldview
Bill Clinton is literally black and
Clarence Thomas is literally not it is a
mind so race isn't just literally the
color of your skin it is a set of ideas
and you know class and all these other
things that get packaged into it so yeah
when they say that Larry Elder is this a
very notorious example who ran for
governor California was called the black
face of white supremacy they weren't
being ironic and or anything like that
this is really kind of makes sense given
their premises it it is I remember
watching this documentary on a heroin of
mine who is Rachel doelle okay oh yeah
did you see when she got trolled on
Cameo yeah oh yeah yeah did they
actually bought me a cameo for my 40th
birthday from her yeah it was a very
nice touching moment but there was his
really we should dig that up and play it
oh of course we do have a special this
is a video message for you mate have a
look at
this hi Francis this is Rachel doal and
I just wanted to wish you a very happy
birthday happy 50th this little shout
out is from squirrel and I hope that you
have a very very happy birthday do
something fun to celebrate and also um
best of luck for your exam that's coming
up um in March this month so I hope that
you do well I hope that your studying
goes well for that exam too and most
importantly happy happy
birthday there you go may your favorite
brown bird wish you a happy
50th what is my [__] life there was
this really interesting moment in her
documentary where it obviously came out
the TR the truth came out as it always
does that she's not black and she was uh
doing a talk in front of these black
students and this girl put her hand up
and she went you're not black because
you haven't earned the right to be black
and that to me was so interesting
because it's not an immutable
characteristic it's something that you
have to earn you have to suffer for it
which to me is a completely bizarre way
of approaching race why is it bizarre
because if in in their subculture or
this world worldview suffering is
valious which is you know it kind ofr a
generation of the Christian ethic so of
course it's going to be like I've
suffered therefore I'm a ous than you it
makes perfect
sense it does it does make perfect sense
but when you think of race as a mutable
characteristic then it doesn't make
sense but they don't use language to
communicate they use language to
manipulate so it's irrelevant so let's
talk about that because I think that
that fundamentally is what pisses me off
the most about what's going on words
have
meaning depends on I I mean I I don't
I'm not trying to be pedantic but it one
context yes and another context
no so that you say that they're not
using language to communicate they're
using language to manipulate right why
why do people manipulate yeah to for
power for status I mean I mean this is
you don't need my insight on this right
so how do we deal with
that um well this is the part we talked
about at dinner
that uh I think what the all seriousness
the way to deal with it and and I don't
think you're there yet I'm not trying to
be mean is once you understand that many
things will go will grow clear to your
understanding right you stop getting
frustrated when you see like oh how
could you say you know that Clarence
Thomas isn't really black you know or so
and so forth magat Wade who lives here
in Austin she's from Africa she's a
great entrepreneur she's very very dark
and when you talk to her about this
thing this stuff she kind of loses her
mind cuz she's just like you know this
makes absolutely no sense I'm a very
dark African black woman and you're
telling me that I'm basically white uh
you're from America I'm from Sagal like
I'm from the motherland I still have an
accent so you know their argument is
language itself is always a mechanism
for powerful people to maintain power so
if it's good for the goose it's kind of
good for the gander and they don't
always realize that they're doing it but
then there's all these little kind of
mechanisms that like white fragility
white rage right so if unless you sit
down and submit entirely like you are
validating white supremacy U I just read
this book um there's this great woman uh
Sarah REO Sai R AO and her she's uh from
the Indian Indian descent Indian
subcontinent and there's is her partner
Regina Jackson and they have these
dinners called race together and you pay
them
$2,000 and it's white women come and
they just tell them how horrible they
are and how they're they're all of them
are Nazis and you know you have to
decolonize every space and it's really
exactly almost like the military or cult
like cult programming they just sit them
down and berate them and when the women
start crying it's just like well that's
just white tears which is your defense
mechanism to not do the work and
maintain your powerful position so like
and then they're like it's funny because
in this book at one point they're like
you know you betrayed your own gender
because 53% of you voted for Donald
Trump who's a known rapist blah blah
blah but then voting for Hillary Clinton
the Democrats of the same as the
Republicans I don't know what they're
supposed to do as a white woman like you
don't have any good options and that's
really smart from their perspective
because if they're running the table and
no matter where you go you lose well The
House Always
Wins we'll get you back to the interview
in a minute but first let me recommend
an incredible alternative to coffee that
will give you that all day energy
without the Jitters in a delicious hot
drink mudwater is made with four
functional mushrooms don't make things
out of dysfunctional mushrooms and only
a fraction of the caffeine you'll find
in a cup of coffee so you'll get that
natural energy without the crash each
ingredient was added for a purpose cacao
and chai for a hint of caffeine and hot
chocolate like Flavor Lion Man for Focus
ceps to promote Natural Energy and both
Chara and RI to support a healthy immune
system it's quality stuff and tastes
like cacao and chai had a baby why you'd
want to drink a baby is anyone's guess
but there we are Plus it's Whole 30
approved 100% USDA certified organic
non-GMO glutenfree vegan and kosher so
not only does it taste great you can
also give it to your woke mates right
now you can save $20 plus get a free
sample of creamer and a free fro by
going to the link in the description
below or heading to
mwr.com /t trigonometry that's mud e
wt.com
trigonometry to save $20 on your
subscription and claim your freees and
now back to the
show what it sounds like is you can't
actually win the argument because it's
not being done in good faith because
it's not an argument it's a battle right
yeah yeah very well said that sounded
more like intellectual emotional BDSM
than I actually tweeted that out that if
I I I I I I was not joking I I put on my
freying hat and I said uh this is un uh
sublimated BDSM uh um these women should
be reading 50 Shades of Gray and not
ibram kendi because it's very clearly
that they're getting off on some way of
the degradation and the masochism right
it's serving some purpose in their
psychology these white women so come
back to to the argument with the so what
that says to me is the idea of the
marketplace of ideas is kind of that's
not going to work here most that's not
true there's lots of in any Marketplace
you're going to have shitty products and
you have products for example liquid
death is just water but people buy it
because it's got the cool label it makes
no sense but they pay a lot of money so
a lot of times you want the packaging
instead of the product Yeah we actually
went into a store here and one of us
what's Liquid death and they're like
it's just water yeah and I I was I I the
first time I CU I thought it was some
kind of cool beer and I'm looking at I'm
just like what the I I I'm just like
good Lord I mean it would be a good name
for water in Venezuela
completely
contaminated but um thanks for cheering
us yeah yeah I thought so I thought it'd
be funny it's just depressing but it's I
always I thought of this I I wrote this
out how essentially identity politics is
just the weaponization and monetization
of white guilt it it's in part yeah and
and you just think it just shows how
actually the point that we come that you
said originally emotions are stronger
than reason
yes it's completely true cuz you look at
all these people or a lot of these
people who are afflicted by whatever you
want to call it mind virus ideology
they're all very intelligent they all
went to the best universities it's
easier to train a smart dog than a dumb
one you have to have a certain amount of
intellectual heft to engage in the
mental gymnastics to keep a ridiculous
philosophy uh in your mind and it also
is a point of Pride was a tertullian uh
you know I believe because it's absurd I
think that's kind of a
mischaracterization of his actual views
but the point being it makes you feel
it's kind of a any kind of mystery
religion where you initiate into the
faith and you understand things that the
normies regard as absurd you know that
is something that is a point of Pride
not a point of Shame you have access to
secret knowledge or hidden knowledge yes
and you understand things that everyone
else could never understand because to
them would be ridiculous right so it's a
status thing so on the one hand that
sounds pretty bad on the other hand you
think we've gone past PE woke now yes uh
I can prove that we've gone past Peak
woke okay again I'm I'm getting
triggered cuz I'm P I'm appreciating the
the reaction if when you say something
is not as bad as it was before they hear
oh it's not a problem anymore right
right so it's like you know like I had
cancer and I have the flu oh so you're
saying the flu is fine say flu no I'm
just there Peak woke is is pasted I'm
not saying W's not a problem I'm not
saying cancer culture is not real I'm
not saying this is okay I'm not saying
can I interrupt you there do you know
what what pisses me off about the world
that we live in is that whenever you
want to say something
obviously you you know whenever we want
to say something now we have to do all
these [__] 50 caveats whichever side
is going to get triggered by what you're
saying because the average human mind is
a series of mouse traps and those mouse
traps are triggered when they hear
certain phrases yes so you know
perfectly well there's certain phrases
and certain uh constructions that people
have pre-loaded speeches and you know
what those speeches are going to be so I
think people who work who have the kind
of work that we do and travel in the
circles that we do we know exactly what
certain things will trigger certain
specific mindless reactions yeah but
anyway Peak woke what woke is still a
problem but you I mean just to explain
for those people who might get triggered
the idea of peak woke is you know work
gets worse worse worse and worse you get
to the point where it's at its maximum
and we are now on the Downs slope in
your opinion I don't know if it was at
its maximum but maximum it could have
gotten worse but I'm saying it's not as
bad in current year as it was two or
three years ago and I can demonstrate
this easily because there were many
people I there's a I can give you one
personal example I personally helped get
Roseanne Bar back on Twitter Roseanne
Bar was cancelled they literally
canceled her show they killed off her
character she's been declared a racist
she's been read out of Society she's got
a successful podcast she's back on
Twitter uh companies are advertising
with her they did not succeed in
cancelling her there's lots of other
people who were just vanished and the
whole point of cancel culture isn't that
like just you're fired from your job it
used to be this person is read out of
polite Society you can they're
radioactive you can't engage with them
Pauline is back on YouTube uh Kurt Meer
a comedian buddy of mine had this great
bit um cuz he did the research about PA
cuz she got her life ruined because I
think it was a court filing she
acknowledged that she had used a racial
slur right at one point in the past and
Kirk did the homework and he goes what
happened was like in the 70s or 80s she
was a bank Clerk and she was like robbed
that gunpoint and that's when she used
like the n-word right and Kirk goes they
should build a statue to her this is the
the most Progressive old southern white
lady ever cuz she had to be traumatized
into saying this he goes they should
build a statue and bring kids around and
the statue should say she only said it
once but because she admitted this her
life was ruined but now she's back it's
not as back as what she was before and
that maybe that's not a good example in
that regard but there's lots of people
Trump is is a good example like even
2015 2016 this person's evil literally
Hitler the cover of the Daily News had
him said Antichrist like where do you go
from there there's lots of people who
you know he's back on he has access to
Twitter and so on and and uh YouTube and
other um uh agencies are now admitting
okay we're not going to be as heavy on
the disinformation because you don't
need a majority you just need an
alternative and having Elon having
Twitter and having a space where this
shit's not going to fly right away you
don't have that uh monopolistic or
oligarch oligarchy where you have like
four or five agencies controlling the
whole market and the rest of them were
like all right there's no point in US
putting in these resources because it's
not going to accomplish our goal of
having this kind of uh um hegemonic
hegemonic control over the microphone
and what happened rosan tell everybody
how that went down well she was tweeting
about Valerie Jarrett who was uh uh an
adviser to President Obama who was born
Iran who is passing you know she uh
she's African-American and Roseanne had
this tweet about the Iran deal she goes
uh plan of the Apes and Muslim
Brotherhood had a kid equ had a baby
equals valy Jarrett and rosanne's like
it's like oh you're calling a black
woman an ape and and so on and so forth
and you know this is someone who's a
lifelong leftist who fought very hard
for uh you know black rights civil
rights and was known for this but on her
show the character became a trump
supporter so and one of her writers even
explicitly said this Show's
humanizing Trump
supporters um and right so this was
something that had to be stopped so you
know they canceled her within minutes
the the rest of the cast threw her under
the bus people who had their homes
because of her you know who knew her for
many years uh she's Liv she lives here
now I've become friends with her which
is one of the greatest things ever to
talk to like Roseanne Bar and hear her
do that laugh was was her show as the
popular in the UK as it was here okay it
was it was it was put on kind of like a
6 p.m. slot but it was still a huge shot
yeah and then she had the the ofon
incident as well that was my
fault I'm not kidding so when I did my
book the new write I had never
encountered literal Nazis before okay
and when I and or Holocaust deniers and
what I learned is the there are very few
Holocaust deniers the Holocaust deniers
are people who say the numbers are
exaggerated but I was like wait wait
wait you're saying like only like
200,000 people died including many
children and like that I'm like I'm like
wait what like I I thought like okay if
they're going to say no one died that
makes more sense to me ethically or
emotionally than like the numbers are
exaggerated and like lots of lots there
was only two million I mean it's really
crazy who hasn't done that I mean stop
whining get on with it who hasn't been
there so I when I talked to them what
was F fascinating is that they thought
that the Holocaust never happened but
should have right and everyone's going
to take that clip now and ruin my life
she thought she is very Jewish she
identifies as a rabbi and she's like
well I never said I was a good one um so
she's on theovon show talking about
things that are kind of you're not
allowed to say she goes yeah Joe Biden
didn't get a uh uh Joe Biden didn't get
81 million votes and six million Jews
didn't die in the Holocaust but they
should and they took that clip and they
Roseanne Bar Holocaust den and it was
insane to me to watch how quickly got
thank God for Twitter cuz the community
notes which is a feature for people all
know on Twitter is if someone posts
something disingenuous the community can
add a note to it to provide context and
immediately the community note said this
is part of she's being sarcastic here's
the full clip this is discussion of
things that you are not allowed to say
on social media and to equate
questioning an election with questioning
the Holocaust you know is also complete
intellectual dishonest but it it didn't
take whereas a few years ago this would
have absolutely wrecked her do you know
when uh in the UK when I think we reach
Peak woke is there was a two-time male
rapist called Adam Graham in Scotland
and uh the moment he got convicted he
descend he developed a prison onset
gender dysphoria I would do that yeah
and then he got put in a female prison
and then there was understandably uproar
because you know he she is now a woman
and you're putting this two- time male
rapist in prison and then there was a
very famous interview with the Scottish
first minister at the time uh Nicholas
sturgeon oh I love her she she's also
trans basically I mean just th that
haircut sweethe exactly trans mixed with
a potato but um I thought that was Irish
no she does look like a potato but then
they were saying to her well trans women
women and she went yes yes and he went
well what about Isa Bryson and went yeah
but Isa Bryson not a woman so goes oh so
in the context of a prison then trans
women aren't women she went yes but but
trans women are are women but in the
prison context there is no automatic
right for a trans woman there are
contexts where a transwoman is not a
woman no there
is there is circumstances in which a
transwoman will be housed in the male
prison estate because any context in
which a woman born as a woman will be
housed in the male estate look we're
talking here about trans women and I'm
now asking about women born as women I
don't think that are circumstances is
there H but so it's different for trans
women well yes and I'm not so they're
not equal that is not the there is a
risk assessment process done for trans
women that takes account of the nature
of the crime it clearly it significant
concern arises out of sexual crime and
whether it's appropriate for them to be
in a female prison or a male prison and
you could see it slowly crumble in her
brain and then there was this other Bea
I got to was it crumbling in her brain
or was it Crum like how do I weasel my
way out of this I I wonder I actually
genuinely Wonder because I do think that
I have seen this happen with people
particularly when I'm debating them or
whatever where you can see that glimmer
of like oh what I'm saying doesn't make
any sense suddenly it sort of starts to
click I I remember I was talking to my
college roommate about uh uh
discrimination laws and I said in Las
Vegas or in Nevada maybe not Las Vegas
prostitution is uh legal or or
decriminalized I don't remember exactly
and I said what if you had a a woman who
was racist escort or prostitute and she
wouldn't want to have sex with black
people would legally you force her to
and he's like oh I have to think about
that I'm just like okay like okay I'm
out you know but it's just it's amazing
when people are it's almost worse when
they're logically consistent CU then
it's like do you not even hear where
you're cuz sometimes you know if you
follow your logic and you end up
somewhere in the wrong place you're like
who whoa whoa whoa I need to let check
my work cuz this conclusion is something
I'm not comfortable with but when you
have this kind of you know thinking they
just bite the bullet and that's what
makes it scary yeah indeed and but and
then there was question time which is
our most prestigious debate program they
were talking about this particular case
and a former guest of the show Ella
wheen said to a member of the Scottish
Parliament member of the SNP the ruling
party they went is ISA Bri
a man or a woman and
she and she went is ISA Bryson a man or
a woman and then the Scottish MP
responded with the words they're a
rapist and you just heard this grown
from the
audience wow and but it comes back to
your point which is they use language to
manipulate and if you use language to
manipulate then the truth isn't real
right there is no truth truth is not
relevant so it's real but it's not
relevant right because it's it's it's
unpalatable no no it's because it's not
the way the conversation is being had
yeah it's not about the truth it's about
who wins the power game of and you see
this on social media at the time people
are interested in seeking like people
try to argue with you they're not
looking for uh you know let's kind of
have this you know Socratic debate or
you know this not Socratic but just like
have a debate and we'll come out of it
some you know and some version of the
truth it's more like they just want to
one up you or play gotcha yeah yeah
we'll be back with Michael in a minute
but first let me tell you about these
superbeat heart chws we've been using
here at trigonometry Towers if you're
looking for a way to turn your snacking
habit into an easy way to support your
health without sacrificing flavor then
heart tubes may be the perfect solution
paired with a healthy lifestyle the
antioxidants and super beats are
clinically shown to be nearly two times
more effective at promoting normal blood
pressure than a healthy lifestyle alone
for me the best thing about super beats
heart chewes is is that they're a great
way to limmit my caffeine intake I
really love the chews have replaced my
midm morning coffee because the chews
support healthy circulation you not only
get blood pressure support but you also
get heart healthy energy which comes
importantly without the crash the chews
are incredibly convenient no pills to
swallow no ingredients to mix or prepare
they're very easy to add to your routine
double your potential with super beats
heart chws get a free 30 day supply of
superbeat heart chws and 15% off your
first order by going to getup beats.com
and using promo code trig that's get
super
be ts.com code trig now back to the
interview that all said we're past Peak
woke what does that mean for where we
going I am very hopeful for the future
of many aspects of the West Canada I
think is in the short or medium term uh
hopeless but I would be giddy to be
proven wrong because a lot of times it's
easier to come back to the light when
it's really really dark you know like
sometimes like relationships if the
husband is only a little abusive you
stick it out for like a very long time
because you could tolerate it but then
like once he gives you a black eye in
many case like all right now it's a wrap
so it's it's like boiling the Frog it's
like people are are comfortable with a
certain amount but maybe there's a point
where it's a breaking point so maybe
Canada actually is more hopeful than the
states although my money would be on the
states um go ahead no I was going to say
I am complet I'm in agreement with you
there is a caveat in that I think if
Trump gets reelected it's going to flare
up again what will flare up the
wokeness uh I don't think so and here's
why I I I think the anti-trumpism will
obviously flare up to an enormous extent
but I think the wokeness uh there's
wokeness in the activist class and
there's wokeness in the elite right and
the elite only care about wokness in so
far as it maintains and controls their
power right uh back in
20156 you could not stop from hearing in
the states about refugees welcome we
need more Muslim immigration that Linda
sarur was this uh Greta thunberg figure
that they just brought her out every
five minutes and she's the spokesman for
this whole movement that's completely
vanished and completely gone away you
literally never hear them talk about
this this was a total Victory by the
right but since so many people on the
right here regard themselves as
Perpetual victims and just Al only want
to complain about whatever the leftists
are talking about right now and they
live in a Perpetual present they've
completely forgotten that this was a
battle that they've totally won so the
wokeness is blowing up in their faces
because Ma Karen who's the swing voter
in America the Suburban mom when Karen
is seeing what's going on with these
Schools she's going right like hard
right so they'll be more than happy to
throw this um over the side of the boat
if it doesn't serve their purposes now
the activists won't be happy but I I
don't know if you guys are aware of this
Biden and kamla Harris get elected and
the heads of BLM were publicly
complaining that they wouldn't take
their calls so they didn't even have
them like some kind of like oh yeah go
me with KLA Harris We'll have beers
photo op they wouldn't even bother
returning their calls and this is public
so I think people underestimate cuz so
much of um social media and political
media is just about like right versus
left how little behind the scenes to
many people this actually matters and
how much of it's a smoke screen that's
very interesting and it was always going
to be once you started to involve
people's kids in this there was only
ever going to be one I mean I said this
from day one the trans thing will be
what breaks us because you start messing
with people's kids I mean I told you a
story about a fan of our show over
dinner who who's who's kind of a default
liberal don't particularly interested in
politics but the daughter comes home
from school one day very expensive
School in New York and I was like Mommy
am I a girl am I a boy rather and she
goes why and she goes well I play soccer
don't I and once you get to that I said
no you're a
foreigner once you get to that point
you're going to you're going to lose a
lot of people I I'm I'm not trying to be
a contrarian but I do want to I think
this is just an important point to the
audience I think people underestimate to
what extent uh privileged especially
white women are willing to sacrifice
their children uh for the altar of
status um and for them having a trans
kid is like winning the lottery right
and you laugh but it's it's really the
case it's very disturbing uh they're the
only ones bringing their kids to drag
shows because for these off affluent
white female liberals awful h a man in
makeup is like the second coming and you
know they're showing dad or their
husband or whoever how enlightened they
are because this is what corporate iMed
corporate media tells them so they can't
wait to bring their kids and and you
know show how uh you know with the
program they are so they are a menace um
and this in my opinion is munchow by
proxy you know they're torturing their
kids for the sake of status and
accolades yeah yeah but there are
minority is my point Sorry France just
to finish sure but but it's it's it's
power no no it's [__] awful but what
they are doing is redpilling a hell of a
lot of normies it's it's also red
pilling to the extent that you realize
this isn't a conversation right like if
I sat down with you and we're friends
and I start talking to you about how
you're going to raise your kid this
isn't a conversation it's it's if it
doesn't get to violence like thinking
you thinking violence it's your first
reaction is like what are you even
talking like what the hell are you
talking about like this is crossing a
line that is so sacred it's it's
ridiculous so I think that is healthy in
the realization that this is not a
discussion you when you're when you're
you could discuss like marginal tax
rates you know social safety and so on
and so forth when there's such an
asymmetry in the consequen of discussion
very quickly it's like this isn't
something that could just be left to the
hopes that I win a debate because maybe
I'm an articulate or so on and so forth
or maybe I'm you know don't have the the
the class or the money to back up my
position but if you're even risking my
kid my only reaction isn't to continue
the conversation my reaction is I have
to get my kid away from you yeah yeah of
course and and you see some of these big
Hollywood actresses and they've got you
know two trans kids and you go there is
something deeply a miss here deeply a
Miss yeah and it becomes a status
symbol and you think to yourself This is
a society that has lost its moral
compass well the other thing that is
never discussed in this this context
which I think is very important is it is
very widely understood that if a woman
is pregnant or going through menopause
right these are hormonal changes it
affects the psychology no one argues ask
any female ask who's pregnant who gone
through menopause they'll laugh about it
it's like oh my God one day I'm crying
one day you know and it's part of the
human condition males who take
testosterone steroids this is heightened
aggression muscle mass all these other
things that happened the idea that okay
I'm a male or female it doesn't have to
be a kid and I'm going to take hormones
and it's only going to have positive
mental consequences is insane because
again taking out the trans isue when
human beings hormones are changed it
affects Behavior hormones are how
animals and humans are animals regulate
behavior in many regards but this is
just completely not talked about it's
the the focus is on the surgery but it's
like if you take these pills or these
injections it's going to screw with your
head so this whole idea that like
imagine saying I what percent of
pregnant women you know have suicidal
ideation I don't know what that number
is but it's not going to be the same as
nonpregnant women it's they're going to
have some sort of disorder thinking
maybe it's not suicidal issue maybe it's
depression maybe it's anxiety postpartum
is obviously very much a real thing uh
and I'm sure hormones have a part to
play in that but this effect of hormones
on the on the psychology no one talks
about and it's extremely gerine to the
issue at hand yeah and also the thing
that I really worry about Michael is
this
if we are correct and we're past Pete
work brilliant that is something to
celebrate what I worry about now is the
backlash because there's a lot of people
who are very very angry yeah we talked
about this yeah and they don't want
Justice they want revenge oh yeah I want
revenge oh no no no I'm I thought you
meant like the growing homophobia yeah
yeah but this is what I mean this is
what I mean this is what this is going
well you know you liberals you wanted
gay marriage this is where it's ended up
so now I'm going to get mine yeah the
it's it's I remember I've talked about
this somewhat recently I remember I only
recently was reminded of what New York
City was like in the 80s when the AIDS
crisis was
decimating largely and at first in you
know the gay artistic community and
there was this sense of kind of Glee and
like you asked for it and and one things
I was I just watched this great U
miniseries called angels in America U
which was very award wi winning and and
and um Tony Kushner is yes and and had
many accolades and there was this and
the thing that Disturbed me the most or
not the most but was knowing that many
of these young men because what happens
is January you have a cough and you're
diagnosed December you're dead right and
you're not just dead overnight you go
scile first and you you're covered in
carosi saroma which are these little
spots so it's very clear who has it
towards the end and then your friends
are all getting it and it's just this
kind of sense of paranoia many these men
went to their graves thinking this was
God's punishment cuz why is are only me
and my community getting this you know
what I mean he were very much being
singled out uh and it was only when you
know kids started getting it through
blood transfusions when uh bisexual men
were spreading into women uh then it
became kind of more of like our problem
instead of their problem but that sort
of thinking um is coming back um and I
don't know if it's inevitable but if you
you have this intersectionality and this
insistence that trans and gay and
bisexual and lesbian it's all one
package deal well for most people who
are binary thinkers well if you're
forcing me to choose between the kid
stuff and everything else and hating it
all well kid stuff's not an option so
I'm going with the hatred yeah so um any
kind of nuance in this regard is is lost
and uh I think a lot of people saw this
coming and it's it's a uh very
disheartening to say least I and I
talked to quite a few gay men because
they watch a show and they said there's
now a real split within the gay
community I hate that term but let's use
it
for between older gay men and younger
gay men because there's a lot of older
gay men who can see the backlash coming
and can see they remember yeah and
they're they're
going we're stroking forces here and you
need to be aware of what is coming and
because of the younger gays haven't seen
it they've got no idea right cuz you're
20 or 25 your entire world was like
seeing Pride Flags everywhere and
channels dedicated to you and oh my God
you're so fabulous and all this other
stuff whereas you know people who are
much older they're like you know I I
remember when I was in high school
arguing with my dad because rup Paul
wasn't out and I'm like you don't know
that RuPaul's gay because the logic was
Gay's bad yeah this person's same with
actors and steroids right steroids are
bad this actor is a good person
therefore this actor is not on steroids
you what I mean it's all these guys who
just become jacked overnight oh they're
not on steroids they just have special
exercise no one else is doing so it's um
it's coming back it's clear social media
people say Twitter is not real life
social media is how you can tell what's
going to be in the corporate press and
corporate media in five years I mean it
it just feeds it's the predecessor so
it's coming down the pike and I don't
really know uh what to say or do about
it there's also an interesting thing
which uh obviously there's been a big
spat between Elon and the ADL about and
semitism yeah um and I think it's fair
to say that all sorts of
uh I'm using inverted commer here but
hate speech is more visible now on
Twitter um that's because they're doing
less moderation and it it's probably
it's probably the price you pay for
having less moderation um but it seems
to me like that is an issue that's also
potentially part of the backlash how so
um I see a lot of people quite openly
talking in a way that is
um oh yeah I see what you're saying yeah
yeah but I mean I I I think the ADL is
is a very evil Organization no no I
agree in this instance I agree yeah yeah
but but just more broadly I think
there's a lot of talk on the right by
the left I mean anti-Semitism is a
bipartisan right no so I I agree because
there if their perspective which I don't
think they're entirely correct is if
you're choosing if you're forcing me to
choose between the ADL and being
anti-semite a lot of them are going to
choose to be anti-semite because the ADL
in my view and it's pretty indisputable
are completely disingenuous a high rck
who runs Libs of Tik Tok is an Orthodox
Jewish woman and they try to get her
canceled uh in favor of trans rights so
you're not really fighting for you know
protecting Jewish people and the right
to speak you just have a hardle uh
gangster mentality you're going to pick
and shoot and how it works is and what
I'll be delighted to point out this
technique because once you figure out
techniques that corporate journalists
use not only do you see it anywhere it
becomes less efficacious so it'll be
like you know Jeff Smith who was
regarded as uh uh hate Monger by
independent Watchdog groups and they'll
have a hyperlink and you click on the
link and it's always the ADL or Southern
poerty Law Center so they work hand
inand they the ADL and Southern Property
Law Center label people as radioactive
or Clansman or Nazi then the journalist
could be like I'm being objective this
is my source I'm not saying it they're
saying it so they feeded off each other
like a snake eating its own tail use the
word snake advisedly uh and and once you
see this every time I I encourage people
watching this click that link it will
invariably one be one of these two
organizations that are used as a source
I mean and that is so dangerous that is
so dangerous because the way that we
casually fling these words around
without don't say we I mean we as
Society but we there is no Society there
is just us yeah yeah okay point taken
thank you Mr no but I'm serious that
when you use that word we I am not in a
community with these people yeah okay
agreed so when you see those people
throw those words around as if they
don't have very very real meaning right
what they've done to the word Nazi is a
crime to decouple Nazism from
anti-Semitism is so ahistorical and
intellectually dishonest and and also
when you use things like climate um
climate denier to piggy back of
Holocaust denier you people have no
shame yeah because again they don't use
language to communicate but to
manipulate and and it's also as well
it's you know you don't have an
understanding of History you have no
understanding yeah they do they don't
care don't you get it they don't care
Francis but but it's also there's an
ignorance tied into it as well because
all they want to do is its surface level
a lot of all they want you to do they're
talk they're trying to manipulate Their
audience to get them to do what they
want it's not that they don't understand
they don't want you to understand don't
you get it they don't think Trump's a
Nazi his daughter converted that's not
compatible with
Nazism Jud this is what I keep saying
Michael because it's it's like I mean
you're right I mean I am persuaded by
what you're saying because if I I keep
saying this if you thought Donald Trump
was a Nazi if you actually thought he
was Hitler the day he got elected you
would pick up your rifle of course and
you would take to the streets and you
would organized to overthrow that
government by viol and yes and brag
about it if you are a moral human being
that is what you would do yes right but
they don't and they call people Nazis
but they don't act in relation to them
as if they're Nazis right they all they
do is it's a it's a tool it means out
group it means bad bad person yes out
group is even better yeah and and and
the fact that they've done that to that
word which has a very specific and a
very important meaning it's a [__]
crime yeah it's a crime yes yeah okay
you've convinced me good
Guillotines we're on camera
yeah
[Laughter]
the there was a lot of Gill guillotin
talk over dinner yeah there was a lot
ofe but not enough guillotin doing
metaphor say again not enough guillotin
there was talking but none of doing no
by the way there's a book from the 80s
like a children's book uh called how to
build your own Guillotine right like a
toy model and I bought it and I put a
picture and they pulled it from
Instagram this is all metaphorical
discussion yeah so Michael when you
say they like and again this is because
these are new Concepts I mean this is
what I'm trying to figure out as we
talk what percentage of people do you
think who are the people who are
manipulating with the express intention
of Victory and who and who are the
people who do you think just aren't
looking under the metaphorical car
Bonnet at this stuff and just following
him blindly under the hood under the I
got you I got you I I I I'm an angile um
it's almost impossible to figure out
from you this happens to you guys and me
as well people who see you on your watch
your podcast read your Twitter social
media you're writing they think they
know you intimately it's it's you
sometimes I I constent a great example
of this was when you were on my podcast
and I was clowning you tring trolling
you because you didn't know who Dave
Smith was and you were saying he's a
nice guy and he's a very close friend of
mine I'm like oh God this guy's terrible
and you keep doubling down and I keep
clowning him and it was this great
awkward tension um and then when I
revealed I'm friends with him you know
became clear it was a very fun funny
moment every so often you get a comment
and just like really resonates with you
for a long time one commenter said
they're
lying these guys all hang out together
Constantin clearly knew who Dave Smith
was blah blah who are they trying to
fool first of all you're in England and
we're here so we're not all H Dave's in
New Jersey we're not all hanging out so
that's literally physic impossible but
in their head since podcasters are
psychologically a set and you can
conceptually think they're all together
therefore in real life they must also be
a set together so therefore this is
disingenuous so we it's not knowing how
many of these corporate journalists are
just useful idiots how many of them you
know get what's going on it's very hard
to determine if or not impossible um but
I think the issue is this is systemic it
starts at the universities is
promulgated through the corporate press
and then reaches politicians so the
politicians are actually even though
they're the ones implementing this stuff
are in a certain sense the less least
metaphysically evil because at a certain
point like let's suppose I um was a
Democrat right and I thought Trump's an
idiot I thought this guy had no business
in the White House you know he's
terrible but I didn't think there's any
room to impeach him over it's just one
phone call that some [__] made
I don't have that space as a democratic
Congress person because all of my
constituents have heard for years from
CNN Trump Russia Trump's the devil
trumps the devil trumps the devil so
it's conservatives I think often have it
backwards it's the universities and then
the corporate press that are wagging the
the politics is Downstream of culture
yes right so I'm curious the one thing
I'll just give let me just quickly of
course I I had this poll and I'll
encourage anyone listening to this to
ask themselves the same question if you
had the Supreme Court right and
sometimes when you give people to bad
choices they give me to some good
choices I'd rather have nine Rand Pauls
would you rather have nine random
Democratic senators or if you're on the
right or nine members of The New York
Times editorial board and when you put
it in those terms I think it's really
clear who would be much more reasonable
who would be looking at the law and who
would be more of a Jihadi without this
the
testosterone one of the thing that
one of the things that used to bother me
and perhaps still does and what I'm
hearing out of you is kind of taken me
out of that space is I I hate hypocrisy
sure and all of us are hypocrites to
some extent because we're all human and
no one is perfectly logically consistent
blah blah blah
however I think election interference is
wrong I think election denial is wrong I
thought that in 2016 when Hillary called
Donald Trump an illegitimate president
and when the mainstream media were
pushing the idea of Russia collusion Etc
and I thought it in 2020 right but for
some reason the most people don't see
that and I I still can't quite
understand why well there's no because
there's no such thing as a legitimate
election because if I want you to be my
accountant and I want you to be my
doctor somehow if 100 million people
agree with me I get it unless there's
150 million people who disagree makes no
sense so if you you're going in and
saying I want this person to be my
president the fact that it should be
contingent on a popularity contest makes
no sense that's a different point one
more one more s though and it's an idea
that's so absurd that the only reason we
even take it serious as hypothesis is
that we're training to the contrary
since kindergarten go ahead fine but
you're answering a different point I I
know you're not a fan of of the the way
that the system works right my point is
something else which is people apply
different standards to their own I mean
I'm saying it as if it's some kind of
big Revelation some most obvious thing
in the world people apply a different
standard to their own tribe versus the
out group and and they're correct to do
so why is that because I you can make
jokes about me and say mean things to me
and Pat me on the and you know what I
mean and be condescending to me because
we're Pals some Rando comes up to me and
talks to me like that who the hell are
you so of course we have different
standards for our our people as opposed
to the outside no but that's not what I
mean I think of it as a as a sporting
game right I mean it's a war cuz if you
lose a a baseball game who
cares but for for this system to work it
has to be treated on a long-term we play
an iterative game where you lose this
one I accept it you accept it then I
lose the next one we both accept it and
then it works no it doesn't work it just
one side just dominates the other so it
works for the winners
why does one side dominate the other
because if you have an election and you
have six 60% I have 40% I don't have
anything right but if you look at the
history of the US and the UK the the
left and right kind of they switch over
time no they didn't the Democrats had uh
first of all Democrats and Republicans
don't always port to right and left
because you'll have the right-wing
Democrats problems Democrats in the US
had Congress for 40 years they had it
from 195 uh um 4 through
1994 uh it's it's just it did not switch
at all uh the presidency did switch back
and forth but you from FDR through
Lynden Johnson the only Republican there
was Eisenhower and he was basically
indisputably a leftist there's nothing
particularly conservative that he did
whatsoever so it's not at all it's only
recently that there's been any kind of
right of Center Renaissance on the
national level in terms of Congress uh
relatively recently since the 90s so
it's not it's not it's different for you
guys with the parliamentary system
because it's a binary Choice you're
going to have the Tories then but and I
will bring up again Mrs Thatcher cuz the
whole point in the 70s was you had the
politics of consensus so you had you
know Ted Heath from the Tory of the
authorities and then you have was it kuk
who was K was later k kuk was later who
was before kin was Al someone no I don't
remember who it was whatever you had the
labor guy and they just had what two
elections in 1972 or something like that
and they basically the same policies it
was at Ted Heath the conservative who
brought in like rationing and uh um you
know not have electricity and thra comes
in she goes I'm not for the politics of
consensus I'm for conviction politics
I'm gonna you know say F you and if you
don't like it don't vote for me but
we're going to have a different point of
view that is not the way the post uh
World War II uh political discourse was
had it was very much consensus let's
work from the middle and you know in
retrospect it was kind of this quasi
socialist Center left middle but but
that's the way it was and I don't why am
I switching I want to win why letting my
opponent win half the time the system is
set up I can tell why you're not
married but I I make the joke but but I
have to say that way of
thinking does prevents you from
cooperating with others and cooperation
is necessary I I don't I disagree I
think my way of thinking is a useful
long-term approach because if you have a
dedicated
uh radicalized minority they are going
to punch way above their weight and we
can see this just as we discussed
earlier with the gay rights movement
because in the 90s it was completely
anathema you cannot speak of this even
in mainstream television and now if you
go to Time Square and I'm sure Picadilly
it's rainbow Flags you know from Pillar
To Post yes yes so this was a small
group yes who had intense convictions
and they won
resoundingly there was had disproportion
cultural power as well that's true yes
yes but what we're talking about in
terms of my joke about I can see why
you're not married any relationship with
other people
requires give and take on both sides
whereas you want to win every time no
matter what yes I always get which
doctor I want unless he's busy I always
get which lawyer I want I get whatever I
want in the store as it does everyone
else assuming you could pay the price so
this idea that in politics I'm not going
to get what I want all time is
nonsensical but in order for you to get
what you want you would have to be
voting for someone to represent just you
or you have to abolish the system that
allows someone to rule over
me tell me more so this whole de
democracy is is is just an obscenity
that must be destroyed and I'm very
heartened that every metric is showing
that people's faith in these long-held
cultural institutions is not only being
destroyed but in an extreme
Direction all right Michael I want hear
all about why the destruction of
democracy is great but we've done over
an hour so the rest will be on locals
head on over there to see the rest of
this
conversation where has anarchism been
successful in
[Music]
history